- [Both] Merry Christmas everyone!
(salsa music)
All right, merry Christmas everybody!
Great to be here.
Been an amazing year.
A lot of milestones passed.
Got the book out.
Got the 500,000 subscribers.
Super excited for the
year ahead into 2017.
And this is going to be
a quick video because
we are in the car as you can tell.
Nina is beside me, Hayden's in the back.
Oh, there he is, what's up, Hayden?
- Why do you guys wear red?
- Wow that's the.
- It's Christmas!
- Hayden's light, and we're right.
We're doing a quick pit stop tonight.
We're waiting 'til it gets
dark, which it is now.
And we're going to go
check out this amazing home
that has over 50,000
light bulbs turned on.
They decorate their house.
This family called the De Sario family,
every year decorates their house
outside with 50,000
light bulbs to help raise
funds and raise awareness for SickKids
which is a hospital.
- Really?
- Yeah, it's for SickKids Hospital.
To raise awareness for SickKids Hospital.
And this family doesn't live
that far from where we are so,
I thought we were going
to go check it out,
spread some holiday cheer.
We haven't seen it ever before,
so we're going to check it out
for the first time ourselves,
and share in the journey with you guys.
So, here we go!
- Everyone.
- Everyone what?
- I got a Pikachu.
- You got a Pikachu?
Hayden got got his first
Pikachu Pokemon Go.
He's pretty excited.
(laughs)
Good job.
Show it so they can see.
There he is.
- [Hayden] There's Pika!
- Okay, let's go find the house!
(jingle bells music)
This is crazy.
It smells like fire, or something.
All right.
Did you guys see that?
Look!
Look at, that's a house.
That's crazy.
Huh?
What do you think?
- I wish I got my snow pants!
- They're in the car.
- I'd like to jump here.
- Oh no, no.
It's not a road here.
(Evan laughs)
- [Bystander] Really nice.
- [Evan] This is a house.
(Christmas music)
Pretty crazy, huh?
They do this to raise money for SickKids.
You can put donations in the box there,
raising money for the local hospital.
So I think these are them,
the De Sario family.
Pretty cool!
Look at the garage full of lights
they have to put up.
This is what the house
looks like normally.
Okay, let's go!
(Christmas music)
What do you think, Mister?
- 50,000 lights!
- Pretty crazy, huh?
(Christmas music)
That was pretty crazy, pretty fun.
That's a lot of dedication that family has
to raise money for charity.
You guys have a Christmas message, Nina?
Christmas message?
- Merry Christmas!
- Merry Christmas,
that's Nina's Christmas message.
Okay.
- [Bystander] Ho, ho, ho!
- [Evan] There you go.
Hayden, what's your Christmas message?
- Merry Christmas!
- [Evan] That's it?
(Nina laughs)
What else you want to say?
- Merry Christmas.
And I will say Merry
Christmas, and believe.
Yeah!
- Whatever your one word is.
- And whatever your one word is.
(laughs)
- We'll see you soon.
- Have a great Christmas guys,
it's been an awesome year.
Super-pumped for 2017.
And for those of you who
celebrate other holidays
sending you lots of joy and blessings and
have an amazing 2017.
Let's crush it together!